خاصه بعد توسع العمليات الحربيه ونقل
العمليات الحربيه لمليشيا الدعم السريع
الى داخل ولايه الجزيره ول مدينه ود مدني
هذا الامر قد يؤدي الى كارثه صحيه كبيره
في
البلاد اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم البيت الابيض يعلن عن
مباحثات اجراها الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو عبر اتصال هاتفي بحثا فيها تطورات
العمليه العسكريه في غزه ومداها واهدافها
ويذكر ان بايدن شدد على ضروره حمايه
المدنيين لكنه قال للصحافه انه لم يطلب من
نتنياهو وقف اطلاق النار تجدون المزيد من
اخبار حرب غزه في رابط التعليق الاول وزير
الصحه السوداني يقول ان توسع العمليات
الحربيه واستمرارها يهدد بكارثه صحيه في
مدينه ود مدني بحكم انها تعد مقرا رئيسيا
للعمليات الصحيه التي تهتم بعلاج الامراض
المزمنه لاكثر من 18 الف مريض
بالاورام في ظل تقدم روسيه على جبهت
القتال مسؤولون اوكرانيون يقولون ان موجات
من القصف الروسي وهجمات بالطائرات المسيره
استهدفت خيرسون جنوبي اوكرانيا واضاف
المسؤولون ان هذه الهجمات اسفرت عن مقتل
شخص واصابه سبعه اخرين
بجروح وزاره الدفاع التيوانيه تقول انها
رصدت على مدى الساعات الاربع وال الماضيه
ثمان مقاتلات صينيه عبرت خط المنتصف في
مضيق تايوان مضيفه انها رصدت كذلك منطادا
واحدا الى
اللقاء